my guest tonight one of the stars of to
count them two fantastic shows HBO's
berry and NBC's the good place which is
streaming now on netflix please welcome
our really good friend Darcy card and
Darcy how are you I'm good Conan how are
you I'm doing really well I envy you
it's like a Balinese chair you're in
right now yes I'm just feeling the ocean
air no I don't live great I like old
downtown from here that's what you could
just tell people no one would know
that's true
it looks like you've opened a spa it's
just vanity looks I'm getting relaxed
just looking at you how are you doing
how are you during this time I'm I'm
good I'm I'm I feel like I sort of have
it you know I'm not an essential worker
in any sense of the word to uh nacelle
and I don't have kids so I'm like I'm
doing a lot of cooking I'm doing a lot
of eating I'm doing a lot of television
walking watching walking and walking dog
walking you're clearly you're falling
apart I can tell I can tell
actually this is like the first time I
put on makeup and brush my hair you look
great
tell me I know I become friendly with
you and you're a very cool husband Jason
yeah and I I'm so I know you guys you're
a very cool couple in fact my wife and I
tried to hang with you guys
unsuccessfully right hold on Coenen
reach the pandemic happened yeah yeah we
didn't want to nobody wanted to rush
each other was like you want to throw
out a date I'll throw out a date cuz
this weekend no let's next week it's
like the it's very it's what we do you
don't mean nobody solidifies anything
it's like guys will do it at some point
I suspect you and Jason of releasing the
virus just to get out of it
that's because the timing was so
suspicious you were like yeah maybe next
week unless very you said unless there's
some sort of novell virus from the
corona family I think that was part of
it you think that that was that you were
working in a lab at the time okay sure
but
you have no proof honestly you know I
mean honestly truly it kind of puts it
all in perspective of like when this is
all done let's like let's hang let's
jump on the friendships you know doesn't
mean hang what doesn't mean I don't know
but I don't know I think this means
fight okay I know what it means okay
are you you two then yeah side or you
just do stick you have it I mean you
have to go outside right it's so funny
how like a dog walk is one of the
biggest parts of our day it's so
important you know when there's so
little to do that becomes it becomes
like the most important thing that we're
doing during the day we I don't know
we're wearing where I'm I wear them oh
my dogs right here you know it's funny
as you were talking about your dog he
your dog crashed the zoom in the
background this is Denny what's the name
penny penny hey penny I love Penny's
rakish scarf thank you she is not loving
this vibe right now she's like I think
penny entered thinking it was one show
then so the host was I was like I'm good
I'm good
I liked him in the late 90s yeah okay
I'm out of here
yeah go for a dog walk what is your
manner because you're a very chipper
cheerful person I am mad I imagine you
being that way out in the world even
during a pandemic you know what's funny
is I think that I am friendly in normal
life but the mask is giving me almost
like this um boldness like I can't I
truly cannot pass a person without
greeting them in some sort of way
there's this guy the other day that was
playing the saxophone really beautifully
and I sort of like yelled across the
whole park I was like sounds good sir
I've never said sir
[Laughter]
I'm just saying I I question first of
all saxophone that's you literally spit
into a sack and fire saliva out into the
world
it's a giant brass saliva shooter he's
truly spitting he was just spitting into
the world
I'm just droplets hearing here's the
thing here's the thing I went for a walk
yesterday and I was wearing the mask but
I also like to wear this big crazy
cowboy hat in Australia when I was doing
a Travel Show and it's a Crocodile
Dundee hat and I do this thing now where
people pass me and I do that I'm saying
and I realize I'm doing a character who
I don't know I'm like I'm a cordial bank
robber
you know 1880s a hundred percent also
it's smart of you to wear the hat
because if your hair is so recognizable
even if you had the mask on they'd be
like hello mr. O'Brien yeah I see yeah I
know I know
I kind of the boldness goes both ways so
I'm nice to people but also if someone
isn't wearing a mask or so I saw some
like four guys together walking nobody
was really masks right right and I'm
like this doesn't check out what do you
brothers like what what's going on
you'll live together this is know you're
walking so closely I can tell they're
not roommates this was not like a
brother situation it was like something
something's up here so the mask gives me
a boldness I mean it doesn't actually I
don't like go up and yell at people but
I do feel a little bit like more
powerful so I can't see my cone and
watch this watch this
oh my God look at that let's say yeah
I'm with Team Coco Cup you know you
really don't want to be drinking out of
those we're not made in a good factory
no I'm kidding they're fine they're fine
I am drinking a lot Conan it is okay
let's talk about that because that's the
one thing that I that's the topic I am
obsessed with right we've talked about
this before
but it is your time when do you guys you
and Jason yeah if you were to imbibe
what's the earliest you would start
we're not really date
I mean this so there's life there's
normal life and then there's quarantine
like just talking about porns okay great
let's just talk about quarantine we're
not really doing any day drinking but
I'm talking about the second it becomes
dark we're drinking and it's every night
and it's cocktails it's line it's
whatever
it's like while we're cooking there it's
so it's it's so much a part of our
schedule now that if I have things to do
my brain is like you need to get this
done during the light hours because you
will be drunk tonight yeah it's I will
say something like sales of alcohol have
gone up like 40 percent during this time
there's a silver lining to everything
that's an essential business and we all
know that there's gin in that no but I
mean it's it's yeah it can start off
with like I'll just have a little sip of
wine at 6:00
yeah 6:30 that I'll just have a sip of
wine but then you're smoking crack half
an hour later one thing leads to another
the quarantine life and we have to give
ourselves that right now we have to go
easy on ourselves yes I love you wrote
King Lear we're smoking crack yeah yeah
but I don't I don't smoke crack during
the day you know what you're not even
sane you have children and a family are
you watching right now what's your
what's your change
what are your zoom shows I'm watching
okay what we are we're watching so much
TV Morty oh my god wait I'm gonna tell
you something almost embarrassing we are
watching so much TV during the day that
we like blacked out the windows and our
that's true that's shameful that's true
yeah that's a little scary that's a
little tell anybody about that okay
don't worry no one will see this
we we binge succession right we binge
unorthodox we binge Tiger King and all
that stuff um we okay here's here's a
fun thing we've been doing every single
night during dinner time we watch one
episode of Cheers did you did you watch
tears I mean you would be too young oh
I'm so young that's really true but um
I'm serious I mean what I'm saying is
Cheers
is there are a lot of actors out there
of a different generation that didn't
watch that show when it was on we know
it from reruns right that's true I mean
I I do remember when it was on the air I
remember my my parents loved it in my
grandma loved it and she had a big Ted
Danson crush god rest her soul she's
about she's upstairs at your house
yes she's if I had a camera would show
her she's strapped to the ceiling and
she's fine hi grandma Nita she's fine
she's um so yeah we I didn't really
watch it when it was I I didn't
there was no like kids on the show it
was all like sexy adults and I didn't
quite like you were like being Silver
Spoons or something you know I didn't
get enough Silver Spoons Punky Brewster
etc beans Baxter I think I made that up
yeah anyway doing right now right that
show Conan okay beans Baxter there
wasn't beans Baxter I think and I think
it was a kids show but let's move on
okay and get to the essential point if
you're watching cheers and here's the
crazy thing your castmates
on the good place with Ted Danson other
incarnation of Ted Danson it's so
strange
it's so like surreal I told I I told the
rest of the cast all the other oh the
other four of them to watch it now after
having spent four years you know working
with and loving Ted Danson it's such an
interesting thing to go back and watch
the show that sort of made him
who he is yeah a quick conan's if that's
okay oh my god those are loud swallows
and just tell me I think I could hear it
I could hear ear cartilage smashing
against your thing like you know this
other Ted Danson dislike silver hair
Jack you know Ted Danson and then you
see him as Sam Malone yeah for the first
time that's new eyes and it's so funny I
mean he's you know everybody knows Ted
dance it's hot as hell that is no secret
right you know it I know it I know I'm
not gonna go on with that we'll go ahead
well okay um but he's like a different
level of sexy
he's like a sexy he's sexy on Cheers
he's like defined the word sexy he's
like making out with Shelly wrong and
it's so strange for me it truly feels
like um like when you see your parents
make out or something cuz I will be
watching it and I'll be like Oh Ted stop
gross please just watch the show right
right
I love that you said it's like it's like
Conan like when you watch your parents
make out I've never seen that in my life
well your eyes didn't know when I'm dead
inside
[Laughter]
your creepy little freaking creep
Darcie my bestie Jason and I hope you
guys are doing great
thanks for having me I've also heard a
lot of nice stuff about the podcast a
lot of people liked it oh my god people
loved it yeah got so many amazing
comments about yes thank you for doing
it anything okay you know shooting a
really weird movie and you're in it now
okay great I I commit you're right
goodbye the little creep I'll talk to
you later let's start drinking you can
start in like two hours yeah
or even
a half-hour all right cool all right
we'll see you later